we're going to begin with the deadly
Heat and the bad air affecting close to
a third of the country's population
unfortunately we have been here before
take a look at this Haze in cities like
Cleveland Pittsburgh and Buffalo New
York that is smoke from wildfires in
Canada the air quality was some of the
worst in the world in Texas and Beyond
the heat is the number one issue there
at least 13 people unfortunately have
died in this weather it was hotter in
parts of Texas yesterday than 99 percent
of the planet wow we've got complete
coverage from around the country
beginning with Michelle Miller she's in
New Orleans which is also feeling the
heat Michelle Miller I know that New
Orleans is your city but the good times
ain't rolling this morning
they ain't rolling it is hot it is
our real feel of 92 and that heat index
120.
62 million Americans are under these
dangerous conditions heat warnings
watches and advisories and the National
Weather Service says that this weather
will continue throughout this weekend
well into the Fourth of July holiday
across the South most people have no
choice but to lay low during the deadly
Heat Wave unless you're installing air
conditioners it's hot enough to
feel the soles of my shoes hot under
shirt 15 minutes it's gone it's
ridiculously hot air conditioning
specialist Roddy fonstock is moving as
fast as he can in this heat we're
running constantly you know we're
getting calls earlier this year 140 170
degree addicts people have no air they
call us the thermometer may say 99
degrees in New Orleans but with humidity
The Big Easy is expected to feel like a
hundred and fifteen on the other side of
the state the latest heat related death
caused by 97 degree temps in nearby
Dallas Texas Norman Grant sums it up
it's just hot I'm miserable the
temperature inside is home 104 degrees
before a donated air conditioner could
be installed
sweating like crazy MedStar a local
emergency service is Distributing AC
units provided by the United Way that
literally could be the difference
between life and death in Houston some
roads are buckling forcing repair
workers into dangerous conditions
meanwhile people in big cities in the
midwest also need to stay indoors as
smoke return from the ongoing Canadian
wildfires on Wednesday Chicago Detroit
Minneapolis and Washington D.C ranked
among the top 10 metropolitan areas with
the worst air quality in the world
so this is Detroit Michigan
skylines were barely visible flights
delayed and residents are being warned
to stay inside and wear masks Outdoors
my eyes have been watering my throat has
been sore I've been coughing
um it's really and I've been indoors
mostly for the last three days
we've certainly been through it those
massive Wildfire plumes coupled with
this this stretch of heat waves
certainly due to climate change many
scientists say so here in New Orleans
City officials have opened up cooling
centers and shelters for the unhoused
and those will be going through the
Fourth of July weekend Nate
Michelle thank you